[Music]
hello welcome aboard relationship
Airlines I the good advice cupcake will
be your flight attendant today before
you depart on their relationship here's
some important safety instructions in
the event you find yourself in a toxic
relationship hey babe I promise I won't
cheat again it only happened like 12
times
don't leave me also you look ugly that
out yourself first and then don't help
the toxic person at all now find the
eject button on your seat and push it
this will send you far far away from
that person and don't forget your
parachute cord bye Lizzy freely and just
feel free to roam around the land and
when you feel ready find a new healthier
relationship Cooper toxic relationships
[Music]
[Laughter]
Wow they look really great in their
swimsuits body acceptance dance party
yes you you are amazing and not everyone
is going to realize that well you know
what you should do and whisper in their
ear the same Bravo week me too
[Music]
[Applause]
hi friends it's me if one of your
friends seems down-and-out sometimes the
best thing you can do is just be there
for them and dad doesn't work shoot them
with a highly concentrated beam
[Music]